The inspiration for the business model...
...came about from a collective frustration of living in Jakarta.
Go-Jek is an all-in-one on-demand platform...
...that allows users to live their modern lives in a much more easier, convenient way.
What began from just transportation has now expanded to food delivery, grocery delivery...
...and all kinds of payment services like buying airtime top-up for your phone.
You can even buy movie cinema tickets.
Over 90% of our orders are from microenterprises.
Outside of China, we are one of the world's largest food delivery businesses...
...and we are by far the largest digital wallet...
...and the largest transactional platform in the country right now.